هذا هو معبر ديفين على الشريط الحدودي
الفاصل بين بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا وقد غضب
هذا الشكل اغلاق كامل لحركه العبور بين
الجانبين وترقب كبير يزيد الطين بالله مع
مرور عام تقريبا على بدء العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
جميع نقاط المرور من والى فيلاروسيا لا
تعمل خلال الوقت الحالي سواء القطارات
السيارات او الحافلات حسب روايتها تحتاط
من الخطر بقوات من جيشها تدعم حرس الحدود
وترا في خطوات كيف الاستفزازيه كما وصفتها
خطوه نحو مزيد من التصعيد بين الجانبين
الوضع اليوم مع الجانب الاوكراني صعب
للغايه خاصه في ظل استفزازات كيف وتسييرها
لدرونات غير حربيه فوق مناطقنا الحدوديه
هذا المركز هو واحد من بين 32 معبرا بين
الدولتين جميعها مغلقه حتى اليوم المتضر
اكبر حسبه روايه السلطات هم سكان المناطق
المجاوره الذين كانوا يتمتعون بخاصيه
التنقل بحريه بين القرى الحدوديه دون
تاشيره عبور للعمل وتبادل البضائع
التجاريه بين الجانبين عبد الجواد الروش
لقناتي العربيه والحدث من الحدود
البيلاروسيه الاوكرانيه